the jurogan experience uh you've talked
about the
china curfew thing with kids playing a
game yes that's a this is an issue oh is
it they have like they use their parents
or someone else in their family to face
scan their device so then they can use
their device i don't know exactly how
they're doing it sweeping new facial
scans will catch chinese kids playing
past curfew oh whoa this this is even
from july oh so that means they're
scanning kids without their knowledge
like randomly well that's to make sure
they're not playing but then the kids
know that's happening so then there's to
make sure they're not that kind of crazy
government overreach is so bizarre do
you hear about the app they're giving
people in beijing for the olympics
yeah they're giving them this app
to use during the olympics but this app
is listening to every [ __ ] thing you
say everything you do it's like total
spyware
do you think that the us government is
doing that to us as well no chance our
government is
joe amazing who's the most honorable and
honest man who's ever lived
that's why he's the president because
he's the best we have andy is he though
yes are the two candidates that we got
to choose from the best that our country
has to offer i believe we're having this
conversation yeah you've had it many
times so i can i can avoid it but yes
yeah of course our government is doing
that maybe they're not as uh
i don't know
maybe they're better at hiding i i often
worry though
that people think that our government is
maybe
more altruistic than others
yeah china might be scanning faces again
you go back to the patriot act and the
the loss of privacy are they maybe
monitoring it real time i'm not sure i
think our real problem is if people
start saying the only way we can compete
with china
is if we have the same sort of
restrictions on our citizens that china
has
if we have the same ability to monitor
our citizens if we have the same ability
to implement laws the way china does
that's that could be a real problem
because one of the things that china's
done it's so brilliant i'm not saying
that we should do it but it is brilliant
how they've got this connection between
their business and their government
that's inescapable you cannot make these
big corporate decisions whether you're
huawei or one of these big tech
companies they work
you know
[ __ ] hand in glove with the
government
and because of that they make these
they make these decisions not based on
short-term interest of the corporation
in terms of like stakeholders and you
know what the shareholders want and yeah
profits for the quarter they're they're
looking at it in this long-term
commitment like what's going to be best
for the party economically i mean i
guess i can understand that i worry a
lot about quality of life oh and listen
no doubt about it that's the number one
problem the quality of life is terrible
like we have you ever been no oh i've
been to taiwan uh but not for a long
period of time i've been there during a
stopover i've never been there for any
long period of time i was there for
about eight days it was interesting i
went and visited um again when i was
working for crossfit i was
kind of the go-between between crossfit
and reebok so i went to go see where
they made the shoes
um down in fujo china and uh
it's pretty i mean it's wild it's
different
um from the construction the density
uh air air quality perceived air quality
obviously didn't have a sensor out there
but perceived water quality working
conditions working hours it's
i think there's a cost to having the
companies and the government
tied like that there's no doubt yeah i
don't recommend that at all for the
united states it's terrible in terms of
creativity and innovation and the
ability to like have a dream and an idea
and implement it and then become
successful one of the things that we
love about america is entrepreneurial
spirit we love the fact that someone can
like like origin we're talking about
jacob's company or or anything else like
someone can create a company and make
something and put it together and you
know that's one of the things that's
beautiful about freedom is you have the
ability to take a chance to do something
that you you have a dream you can put it
together and make it happen that's we
all love that and when you take that
away take away people's ability to take
a chance and take people's
take away people's ability to do what
they want instead you have to do what
the government wants
as soon as you do that you you close the
door on so much innovation you close the
door on so many opportunities that you
would have never predicted right because
who knows how many ideas
that have been implemented here because
people have this wild spirit of like
being creative and taking chance chances
would have never happened if the same
person grew up under a regime like the
ccp
i do worry though that people
are becoming resistant to taking chances
and being
risky like that or getting off of the
couch if you want to describe it that
way so they'll value that less and the
incremental if you again you want to put
the tinfoil hat on the incremental
removing of those opportunities or
ability to make those decisions they
won't even realize what is lost because
they don't value it because they never
actually took a [ __ ] chance
there's going to be people like that for
sure but
people like that that don't take chances
they
open up room for people that do take
chances i don't think many people take
chances i think there's enough
i think there's enough but i think
they're in the minority i think talking
about it like this
and having conversations with people who
do take chances makes take taking
chances exciting to the people that are
listening i think part of the problem is
they don't have enough
to model there's not enough people out
there that are taking chances where
someone could model that and go that's
what i want to do that's what i want to
be
you know because that's like it's like
who you're modeling like if you if you
grew up in a family where no one takes
any chances and everybody just takes the
safest easiest job they can have with
the you know the least amount of risk
and the most amount of security and
and then they live this
dull gray life like blah
forever
you you model that if that's what you're
around and or you rebel and you rebel
and you take a wild chance and in a lot
of families if you try to take a chance
your parents will be pissed at you i
mean
you know
there's so many people out there that
are hindered and then they're saddled
down by the the problem of their own
family having expectations on them
you're supposed to be a lawyer you're
supposed to be of this you're supposed
to you know there's a lot of people like
that out there that just
the model that they
copy is a model of like safety and where
no one's no one's doing anything risky
freedom is an amazing thing i think it's
the most valuable thing that this
country may have to offer but it doesn't
mean a [ __ ] thing if you don't take
advantage of it yeah
you